thank you
[Applause]
what the [__] Kayla oh wait till you see
the shot I got it looked like you're
gonna [__] a brick out sideways you
could have taken my head off it wouldn't
have been a clean decapitation with
these blades you'd just scramble your
face up real good
shouldn't you go see if Jessica is
feeling any better she'll be fine they
gave her Klonopin so she can sleep off
whatever the [__] is wrong with her girl
is such a pain in the ass
Jessica
hey
how you feeling cuz
since none of these other friends of
yours bothered to show up
can I take your car and escape the hell
of being stuck here with your latest
boyfriend
you better wake up in the next half hour
or I'm gonna be forced to go drown that
brainless meat puppet sorry ass
and
I was going to Daddy
the intense horror of my nightmare came
over me
try to draw back my arm but the hand
clung on in the most Melancholy voice
soft
let me in let me in
spoke I discerned obscurely a child's
face looking through the window
finding it useless to attempt shaking
the creature off I pulled its wrist onto
the broken pain Jess and rubbed it too
shut up and throw till the blood ran
down and soaked to the back clothes get
still and wailed
[__]
[Music]
foreign
Josh
Jessica
[Music]
[Applause]
you in there
just give me five all right Brian who's
losing his [__] we can't find the Strat
he wanted that arm wrestling contest
last night
it's already tuned and rack stage left
like I told you it was half an hour ago
you feeling it right in there
I'm fine
just got my new station
I'll be back before cutting's up
you got it boss
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
somebody got that please
all right all right
surprised
when did you get into town I ubered
stereo from LAX
you've been sleeping you look like Mom
Pete's looking like
you know the downstairs buzzer is
totally busted I was able to walk in
right off the street whole building's
busted it's getting knocked in a month
you're kidding me nope we're out have
you guys found a new place
but not yet
[__] oh you and Jay have been here
forever
was Bangkok awesome insane crazy
obsessive fans over there did you drink
snake blood hey that's culturally
insensitive
what about monkey brain barbecue oh yeah
that's so much better Dan who's your
friend Cass
it's called Stephanie oh
hey Stephanie